[Musique]
et vous l'attendez sans doute avec
impatience le lundi c'est le jour de la
chronique sport de michael et me doro
bon soir en soir et pour parler pour
commencer cette chronique sport du
football la coupe de france
on l'a joué ce week-end exactement
grégory à 8e tour de la coupe de france
versailles qui évolue en nationale 3 a
failli réaliser le plus bel exploit de
son histoire ce samedi 8 décembre devant
plus de 3000 à supporters les hommes de
la cité royale se sont inclinés 4 à 2
face au racing club de lens un club de
ligue 2 après avoir réussi à mener au
score une déception pour le staff
versailles et et les joueurs il était au
micro à votre micro des griquas oui tout
à fait malgré tout et la défaite donc
l'année c est parce qu on a abordé ce
match là pour pour le remporter
on n'a pas remporté ce match mais je
tiens à saluer le courage l'abnégation
et le coeur que que mes joueurs ont omis
sur ce match au fil du match
cette seconde mi temps on a on a pris un
but assez vite mais on a on a baissé
physiquement et c'est là où c'était plus
dur pour nous très très belle ambiance
en tout cas rien pour ce 8e tour de
coupe d'europe mais les ultras étaient
au rendez vous toujours avec
l'élimination l'élimination de
versailles les yvelinois ne comptent
plus malheureusement aucun représentant
en coupe de france rendez vous l'année
prochaine pour vivre de nouvelles
émotions et on a hâte de les retrouver
c'est vers ça y est les prochaines en
coupe de france et on va d'ailleurs
suivre là le reste de leur saison en
nationale 3 du rugby à présent un derby
à rebondissements entre chevreuse et le
sky rugby dans le championnat honneur
plus fort physiquement les chevrotins
archi favori de la rencontre dominé les
débats mais ils se sont fait très peur
dans cette rencontre face à des saint
quentinois qui n'ont rien lâché ils se
sont imposés dans les dix dernières
minutes grâce à deux essais le score
final 32 à 24 en écoute ta réaction
quand même la fierté parce qu'on savait
que ça allait être compliqué c'est une
équipe qui joue le haut de tableau
mais malgré tout les a tenus on les a
tenues avec nos armes avec le jeu et la
solidarité après dommage ça nous ça nous
aurait pas mais on va continuer à
travailler on va retourner
on était optimiste on a gagné mais
sans manquer de se manquer de respect
aux sky je pense que c'est normal qu'on
gagne largement est par contre
voilà qui n'est pas le bonus ça c'est
pas normal par compan au classement
chevreuse domine le championnat honneur
avec six victoires en huit matches de
son côté le sky rugby reste 7e avec 15
points et deux équipes joueront leur
dernière rencontre de l'année ce
dimanche 16 décembre
victoire impérative pour passer de
bonnes fêtes de fin d'année et ces
informations sportives et bien d'autres
encore retrouvé dans un instant dans
votre émission le 7-8 sport merci
michael et